I'm sorry to cut you but I feel like you  guys have the wrong picture of our  friendship honestly because it what you  are saying I would I understand because  personally if I was if I started seeing  a girl and she told me that she has this  really close friend that she had history  with obviously I'm always gonna feel  naturally wait pause pause I'm always  going to feel some type of way about it  however when the guy comes into the  picture and and she's seeing the guy I  will make him feel comfortable because  I'm not trying to cause no situations  because I respect her and I respect the  fact that she's now found a new person  and she's the same with me we don't make  each other's new counterparts feel some  type of way because we have history and  our history again is such a long time  ago that now it's like